. Let's go to your voicemails now.
We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
Here's a really funny voicemail about a pen,
about a fly landing on Mike Pence's had during
the debate.
Take a look, bro.
Kent is not garbage.
A literal fly just landed on this guy's head.
Yes, that's right.
That literally flies are landing on his head.
What's the opposite of when Bernie gets a
bird to land on his on his little podium?
It went off my lands on this race and said
goodbye.
Bye bye.
Yeah.
A lot of people reacting to the fly that that
took hold of Mike Pence's heron seemed to
get sort of caught up in his hair gel.
I read a lot of interesting things about how
I as you know, I'm not religious and I don't
know if this is Old Testament or New Testament
stuff or whatnot, but I guess a fly landing
on your head is considered to be a very ominous
sign, at least in some biblical teaching.
And a bunch of people wrote to me, wrote,
wrote to me about that.
It doesn't resonate with me.
But with Pence being such a religious guy,
it is pretty damn funny.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We will update the Biden Harris student debt
plan.
I think this is important.
And I want to go over it.
We will also talk about 24 super habitable
planets that have conditions that are better
for human life than Earth better.
And we will also talk about the LGBT takeover
of the proud boys hashtag on the Internet.
It is absolutely hilarious.
All of those stories and more on the bonus
show get instant access by becoming a member
at join Pacman dot com.